[Applause]
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has given
fans a lot of info over the last decade
eighteen movies in ten years featuring
five Infinity stones and countless
superheroes to keep track of Wow you're
the Avengers
so to save you the binge watch we are
gonna cram everything you need to know
about your favorite heroes and the
jewelry they'll soon be fighting over
into one handy guide to Avengers
infinity war to start off let's go back
ten years to the first movie in the MCU
Ironman where we meet billionaire arms
dealer Tony Stark after he's captured
and wounded by terrorists
Tony installs a device called an arc
reactor in his chest to keep shrapnel
from reaching his heart and because he's
a board billionaire in a cave he builds
a suit of armor to fight injustice
around the world Tony is supported by
his long-suffering assistant Pepper
Potts his Air Force buddy James Rhodey
Rhodes his bodyguard happy Hogan and his
personal AI Jarvis not Josephus's Stark
defeats his old pal Obadiah Stane who
tries to take over his company using a
huge suit of armor and were introduced
to Phil Coulson agent of shield Tony
publicly admits he's Iron Man I am Iron
Man then Nick Fury breaks into his house
to set up the MCU I'm here to talk to
you about the Avenger in issue next up
is the Incredible Hulk you know the
weird uncle you don't invite to
Thanksgiving we meet dr. Bruce Banner a
scientist who turns into a Green Monster
when he's angry he's played by Edward
Norton in this movie and only this movie
Banner is being pursued by general
Thunderbolt Ross father of his love
interest in this movie and only this
movie Betty Ross Hulk beats up super
villain the abomination in Harlem and
then disappears and the Tony Stark shows
up at the end of further setup the MCU
together that's pretty much I need to
know about this one let's move on Iron
Man 2 is most notable for the characters
it introduces the Tasha Romanoff aka
Black Widow and undercover SHIELD agent
Tony's dad Howard Stark and Rhodey 2.0
now played by Don Cheadle Tony overcomes
the life-threatening illness Rhodey
suits up in his own armor as war machine
to help defeat high tech Mickey Rourke
Sam Rockwell dances and Tony and pepper
get together after the credits we
discovered that Agent Coulson has found
a hammer in the desert which leads us
right into Thor where we travel to the
magical realm of Asgard home of King
Odin his wife Rene Russo and their two
sons Thor and Loki Thor gets himself
banished to earth for being an arrogant
jerk and is stripped of his magical
hammer Mjolnir he falls in love with
skeptical scientist Jane Foster finds
his humanity and gets his powers back
Thor's brother Loki turns out to be an
adopted frost giant betrays his adopted
father then betrays his real father
then apparently dies except not really
because he's back in the post-credits
scene and seems very interested in a
mysterious blue cube also Hawkeye shows
up for like two minutes
moving on to Captain America the First
Avenger
it's the 1940s and a Nazi named Johann
Schmidt discovers the same blue cube we
saw at the end of the last movie it's
called the tesseract and it contains the
first of what we will later learn are
called Infinity stones
more specifically the blue one
traditionally known as the space stone
it's world war ii and little rascal
steve rogers wants nothing more than to
be a soldier like his good pal James
Bucky Barnes enter Tony Stark's dad
Howard who's developed super soldier
steroids that turned Steve Rogers from a
naughty to a hottie he also gets a nifty
shield made from an unbreakable metal
called vibranium the u.s. names him
Captain America and sends him around as
a glorified mascot until Bucky is
captured by Johann Schmidt who reveals
himself to be the eternally sunburnt Red
Skull he's not even a real Nazi he runs
his own sinister organization called
Hydra cap rescues Bucky but this victory
is short-lived while fighting red
skull's forces Bucky dies and cap loses
his best friend Captain American Red
Skull have an epic fight that ends and
skull getting sucked into the tesseract
the cube falls into the ocean and his
lost and cap is forced to crash-land red
skulls bombed Laden plane in the Arctic
years pass Howard Stark finds the
tesseract at the bottom of the ocean and
cap is on ice until he's unfrozen in the
present and recruited by Nick Fury to be
part of the Avengers
Earth's Mightiest Heroes that
troublesome Loki is back and he's been
hired by the other to retrieve the
tesseract in exchange for a massive
alien army and dominion over earth not a
bad trade loki arrives armed with a
powerful scepter that can brainwash
people and his natural charisma this is
my pocket mewling quim
in response Nick Fury finally assembles
the team he's been building for several
movies Captain America Thor Black Widow
a newly Mark Ruffalo Incredible Hulk
Iron Man and Hawkeye who spends half the
movie brainwashed by Loki typical
Hawkeye fueled by Loki's murder of Agent
Coulson
The Avengers battle him and his alien
army in the skies over New York
there's mayhem explosions and that
circle shot of the Avengers that
everyone loves
Loki's defeated Thor takes the tesseract
back to Asgard Loki's staff is taken by
shield and we finally meet the big bad
behind this alien invasion
it's Thanos who is this guy why did he
want the tesseract so badly
what's his master plan we'll find out
eventually Phase two kicks off with Iron
Man 3 where Tony Stark deals with his
PTSD from the big fight in The Avengers
he fights a villain named the Mandarin
who turns out not to be Sir Ben Kingsley
I am the man
blows up all his Iron Man suits gets his
heart fixed and puts Bruce Banner to
sleep what's next
Thor the dark world introduces us to the
second Infinity stone in hiding the
reality stone in the form of a red goo
called the ether a dark elf named
Malekith wants to use it to open up
holes in the sky and join the realms or
something it doesn't really matter the
stone is big it's red it's powerful in
the story Thor's mom dies Loki faked
eyes for the second time but really
takes Odin's place on the throne of
Asgard and natalie portman makes her
last appearance to date in the MCU
Thor's buddies take the ether to a guy
named the collector and we hear the
first MCU mention of the words Infinity
stones the tesseract is already on us
God is not wise to keep two Infinity
stones so close together the collector
seems very interested in catching them
all like some kind of intergalactic
Pokemon fanatic 1 Captain America the
Winter Soldier is it very worried about
Infinity stones instead cap fights to
save his brainwashed best friend turned
international assassin Bucky Barnes now
known as the Winter Soldier it's also
revealed that Hydra has infiltrated
shield turning cap and black widow into
outlaws it's difficult as this is to
accept Captain America is a fugitive
from shield they fight back with the
help of their new friends Sam Wilson the
Falcon and cap allows shield to be
exposed and destroyed cap finds out that
Bucky killed Tony Stark's dad Black
Widow comes out of the shadows and
reveals her identity are you sure you're
ready for the world to see you as you
really are Nick Fury survives an
assassination attempt it goes into
hiding and Bucky is D brainwashed and on
the run wanted by both the government
and his best friend cap but something
strange is brewing and it involves
Loki's scepter from The Avengers now in
the hands of Hydra
meanwhile out in space we're introduced
to an all-new super team the guardians
of the galaxy made up of earthling Peter
quill humor challenged Drax tech whiz
rocket don't call me racoon sentient
tree being Groot and adopted daughter of
Thanos turned assassin Gamora the
guardians are in possession of an orb
containing yet another
infinity stone the power stone which
they bring to the collector for some
very important infinity stone exposition
before creation itself there were six
singularities exploded into existence
and the remnants of these systems were
forged into concentrated ingots infinity
stone long story short the stones are
pretty powerful the guardian stone is
promptly stolen by bad guy Ronan the
accuser on behalf of fan OHS but with
the help of Thanos his other daughter
nebula Ronan decides to betray Thanos
and use the stone for his own evil deeds
which turns out to be a big mistake
poster student the Guardians team up
bunch of jackasses standing in a circle
and used the stone against him leaving
Ronan dead Groot broken down and reborn
as a pint-sized Funko pop Thanos still
without any of this coveted jewellery
and the Infinity stone in the care of
galactic cops the Nova Corps all the way
back on earth it's time for Avengers age
of Ultron where the Avengers are back
together to steal back Loki's scepter
from Hydra and eradicate the last Hydra
stronghold in the process brother and
sister Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
escape after the Infinity stone is used
to give them powers since rights issues
with Fox won't allow them to be mutants
Scarlett which gives Tony a creepy
vision of a possible future franchise
where the planet is destroyed so he and
Bruce Banner set out to create something
that will protect the entire planet
except whuh-oh they accidentally create
Ultron a sinister AI that believes the
only way to save the world is to
annihilate mankind
one path to peace the Avengers
extinction Thor also gets a creepy
vision of a future sequel and Jets off
to see what that was all about Ultron
steals and cracks open Loki's scepter
revealing another infinity stone which
he tries to use to build himself an
unkillable body made out of vibranium
supplied by bad guys smuggler ulysses
klaue from some place called Wakanda I'm
sure we'll never hear of them again
luckily the Avengers intervened steal
the body dump Jarvis's AI into it add a
little for lightning and bing out pops
the vision to the mine stone it's one of
the six Infinity stones the greatest
power in the universe unparalleled in
its destructive capabilities The
Avengers defeat Ultron but not before
the country of sokovia is nearly
annihilated in the battle Quicksilver
dies Hulk flies away in a Quinn jet to
protect his true love black widow Thor
goes into the cosmos to investigate this
infinity stone business the mine stone
is the fourth of the Infinity stones to
show up in the last few years it's no
coincidence and cap in Black Widow ready
a new team of Avengers consisting of
Scarlet Witch division war machine and
Falcon Pharos tired of all this
foolishness decides to take matters into
his own hands literal doing myself
next up is ant-man where we meet Scott
Lang who uses a suit designed by genius
Hank Pym and his daughter hope Van Dyne
to shrink to the size of an ant
he meets Falcon hi I'm Scott that has a
lot of cool fight scenes including a
trip to the quantum realm Microverse
hope Van Dyne is set up to become her
own tiny hero the loss and we're already
running out of time so that's about all
you need to know about this one next up
Captain America Civil War reunites us
with the Avengers as the government uses
the battle of sokovia to pass an act
requiring regulation and oversight over
superhero activities in the past four
years you've operated with unlimited
power and no supervision that's an
arrangement the governments of the world
can no longer tolerate Captain America
isn't on board safe his hands are still
our own but Tony Stark is we need to be
put in check we meet two chala whose
father is murdered in a bomb attack
that's pinned on Bucky to chawla suits
up as black panther and we have a
full-blown superhero war what do we do
can we fight through the manipulations
of creepy bad guy helmet Zemo cap
Falcons Scarlet Witch Hawkeye and
ant-man end up fighting Iron Man Black
Widow Black Panther war machine vision
and hey it's your friendly neighborhood
spider-man everyone in the ensuing
battle war machine ends up paralyzed and
only Bucky and cap escape setting up an
epic final showdown when Tony Stark
learns that Bucky is the man behind his
parents death use calf and Iron Man
Throwdown like only two superheroes can
do disorder ending with cap going into
exile and freeing his captured teammates
Bucky loses an arm and goes back into
cryo sleep in Black Panthers homeland of
Wakanda which we'll see more of very
soon but not before Marvel introduces
yet another hero dr. Stephen strange
arrogant surgeon turned humbled mystic
after his hands are crippled in a car
accident Doctor Strange ends up being a
natural in the mystic arts able to
easily wield the eye of agamotto a
magical artifact powered by the time
stone another one of those pesky
Infinity stones Doctor Strange defeats
the mighty Dormammu master of the Dark
Dimension Dormammu I've come to bargain
and sets up shop in new
or where he meets the god of thunder for
a nice little mid-credits scene that
will pay off later but first we have to
blast off back into space for guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 this movie doesn't
really have anything to do with Infinity
stones we've been hired to stop an
interdimensional beast from feeding on
those batteries but hey it's a fun movie
there's a guy named Heiser face Peter
has to fight his living planet father
and yondu bites the dust but since we're
focused on those sweet sweet stones for
academic let's move on to spider-man
homecoming also not really much having
to do with Infinity stones here Tony
Stark mentors young Peter Parker as he
struggles to balance being spider-man
and surviving high school he fights his
girlfriend's dad the vulture turns down
a spot on the Avengers roster complete
with fancy super suit and possibly
reveals his secret identity to his Aunt
May
speaking of WTF let's make a trippy
return to Asgard in Thor Ragnarok again
not a whole lot of infinity stone action
in this movie but it does put a lot of
pieces on the board for infinity war
Thor's long-lost sister Hallett goddess
of death returns and her native home of
Asgard is the source of her power
forcing Thor to evacuated citizens and
let it get completely annihilated as
long as the foundations are still strong
we can rebuild this place
now those foundations are gone sorry
Odin dies Thor loses his hammer and and
I the Hulk resurfaces as a gladiator
from the Grand Master on the planet
Sekar and Loki teams up with his brother
the Hulk the badass warrior Valkyrie and
the all-seeing Heimdall as they head
back to earth on a spaceship oh and a
massive ship that almost 100% belongs to
Thanos pops up at the end probably
looking for the Infinity stone hidden
inside the tesseract which Loki
seemingly burgled from Asgard's vault
shortly before it was destroyed all of
this brings us to Black Panther the
latest entry in the MCU we're given a
formal introduction to Wakanda home of
T'Challa and the source of all the
world's vibranium which gives Wakanda
incredibly advanced technology that
they've hidden from the rest of the
world picking up after the events of
Civil War we see T'Challa ascend to the
throne of Wakanda becoming its king and
taking the mantle of black panther
T'Challa survives an attempt by his
long-lost cousin Erik kill monger to
assume the throne and decides to go
public and share wakanda's amazing
technology with the rest of the world we
end the movie with the now unfrozen
Bucky Barnes revived and ready to take
on the world in Avengers infinity war so
where does all this leave us Thanos is
coming to earth and the space stone is
more than likely staring him in the face
inside the tesseract the Power Stone is
in the hands of the Nova Corps and
Xander the reality stone was last seen
with the collector on know where the
mine stone is embedded in visions
forehead the time stone is around the
neck of dr. strange and the final
Infinity stone the soul stone has yet to
be revealed but will almost certainly
pop up in the first half of Avengers
infinity war Black Widow Hawkeye ant-man
and Scarlet Witch are hiding along with
Captain America
Bucky's hanging out in Wakanda Iron Man
and Spidey or trading quips in New York
Thor the Hulk and their crew are
somewhere out in the Kosmos along with
the guardians of the galaxy Nick Fury is
presumably still chilling on Hawkeye's
farm since age of Ultron war machine is
paralyzed visions doing his dr.
Manhattan thing Thanos is on the way and
dozens of other background characters
are milling around way
for their close-up oh that is a lot of
info what do you think is gonna happen
next in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
are you angry that we didn't mention dr.
Samuel Sterns and the fact that they set
him up to be the leader but that's never
gonna happen because Marvel pretends
that that Incredible Hulk movie didn't
exist let us know in the comments below
and as always thanks for watching screen
junkies
[Music]
Oh